and you've got the most most starving
suffering people on the in in the
richest country in the world no way you
come from zimbabwe more people are
starving than bob with it here they they
sold me a lemon wait if you come from
zimbabwe to the united states and then
you think that you were sold a lemon
you're not
on this planet zimbabwe is one of the
worst places to live on the planet also
like i noticed that you have some
sunglasses nice nike sweatshirt right
there like
the the notion that that other places
around the world are better than the
united states is rooted in either
insanity or complete ignorance we have
the most starving people on the planet
no
we absolutely 100 do not
we do not have
nearly the number of starving people
that pretty much every other country on
the planet has which is why people were
clamoring to get here i noticed there
was not a lot of reverse immigration
from the united states to zimbabwe for
example